Trascrizione: claudia vettore
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Grazie a tutti.
Devo ammettere che quando Mario
mi ha chiamato per parlare,
per invitarmi qui,
abbiamo parlato di come riuscire
a connettere l'industria chimica -
comunque il settore chimico,
in cui io lavoro -
e l'empatia.
Una delle prime domande
che mi è venuta in mente è stata:
ma che cosa vado a raccontare?
Ma in realtà il link
tra empatia e chimica industriale
l'ho trovato in una cosa molto semplice,
una cosa di tutti i giorni:
un uovo.
Ora vediamo un po' come.
Quando si parla di empatia,
a livello tecnologico, per me,
ci si riferisce a questa domanda:
perché c'è la necessità
di una certa tecnologia
e soprattutto, quali conseguenze ha
a livello planetario.
E il poter riuscire
a rispondere a questa domanda
si collega al concetto di awareness,
ovvero consapevolezza;
ma è una consapevolezza
che deve essere molto solida,
basata su fatti;
non una consapevolezza frivola,
oggi un po' tipica dell'area
dei social e delle fake news.
Ed è proprio questa consapevolezza che,
grazie a tecnologia e innovazione,
può portare a un cambiamento,
soprattutto a livello della società.
Adesso vedremo due esempi,
il primo dei quali è proprio quello
della produzione di uova.
Oggi, fondamentalmente,
ci sono tre grossi tipi di allevamento
per produrre le uova, che sono:
allevamenti in gabbia;
poi abbiamo gli allevamenti
organici, o biologici;
e una via di mezzo, invece,
sono i cosiddetti
allevamenti "free range",
dove le galline hanno la possibilità
di stare sia al chiuso,
in ambiente protetto,
che anche di poter uscire.
Ma andiamo a vedere i numeri.
Oggi, in Europa,
circa il 56 percento delle uova
viene prodotto tramite
allevamento in gabbia,
mentre questi allevamenti
organici, e free range,
rappresentano una percentuale
praticamente molto bassa.
In realtà voglio farvi
anche un altro esempio,
ed è la situazione
della Svizzera, dove vivo.
Il popolo svizzero, nel 1978,
siccome consapevole di questo problema,
del problema degli animali
che soffrono in queste gabbie,
ha votato ed è riuscito, già nel 1992,
a bandire completamente
questo tipo di allevamento.
Ma in realtà, se guardiamo
un attimino i numeri,
questi allevamenti organici e free range
in Svizzera non fanno il 100%.
In realtà il motivo è che siamo ancora,
dal '92, in una transizione;
e questo è un concetto
estremamente fondamentale,
quando parliamo di cambiamenti
a livello societario,
perché più è grande
la scala di cui parliamo
e più questo concetto
di transizione diventa vitale.
Quindi, in realtà, questo triangolo
che ci permette di arrivare al cambiamento
è un po' incompleto,
infatti bisogna tenere
in considerazione questo periodo.
Sarà fondamentale,
come vedremo nel prossimo esempio,
che è appunto l'industria chimica.
Oggi la nostra vita, fondamentalmente,
gira intorno a una miriade
di prodotti, servizi -
pensate ai cellulari,
i trasporti, le macchine,
le medicine, il cibo,
l'elettricità, l'igiene personale -
è tutto basato su questo.
Ma voglio farvi una domanda.
Immaginate un giorno
senza industria chimica.
Secondo voi, quale di questi prodotti -
o chi pensa, per esempio,
che meno del 50% di questi prodotti
non ci sarebbe senza l'industria chimica?
Spesso mi dicono "tutti".
Anzi, spesso mi rispondono:
sì, sicuramente saranno pochi.
Ma in realtà, purtroppo non è così:
praticamente tutti questi prodotti,
tutto quello che noi indossiamo,
quello che c'è attorno a noi,
viene direttamente o indirettamente
dall'industria chimica.
Perché dobbiamo cercare di immaginarci
questo giorno, magari fantomatico?
In realtà, un giorno
senza industria chimica
è un giorno senza petrolio,
perché noi siamo una società
basata sul petrolio,
che nel giro di secoli,
se non facciamo nulla,
potrà fondamentalmente finire.
Vi spiego perché questa società
è fatta così, l'industria chimica.
Praticamente l'industria chimica
è come un albero, semplicemente.
Tutti questi prodotti e servizi
sono come le foglie di quest'albero -
i cosiddetti consumer goods.
Questi sono fatti a loro volta
da "prodotti intermedi", per così dire,
combinazioni chimiche
di prodotti intermedi.
Ancora di più, il tronco di quest'albero
è fatto dai cosiddetti elementi
della chimica di base,
che si possono unire, come un lego,
per fare tutti questi vari intermedi.
Fino alle radici di quest'albero,
dove si trovano i raw materials,
ovvero le risorse naturali.
E pensate un po',
circa il 90 percento
di quest'albero, oggi,
si stima che è basato sul petrolio.
Quindi immaginate
una società senza questo:
non è una società.
quindi [non] potremmo,
probabilmente, vivere come oggi.
Ovviamente,
l'unica vera soluzione sostenibile
che si pensa oggi
è riuscire a utilizzare comunque
l'anidride carbonica,
la CO2 prodotta in questi processi
e riuscire a chiudere
fondamentalmente il cerchio,
per poter avere appunto
una cosiddetta economia circolare.
Il problema è che, oggi,
queste tecnologie hanno
una maturità tecnologica così bassa
che si prevede che arriveranno
a livello commerciale
nei prossimi 50 o addirittura 100 anni;
ma non possiamo purtroppo
aspettare così tanto.
Quindi, come nell'esempio delle uova,
c'è bisogno di una transizione;
e quando noi vogliamo andare
dal petrolio fino alla CO2,
in mezzo deve esserci
qualche altra risorsa
che ci possa garantire
di fare questo passaggio.
Ce ne sono tre fondamentalmente,
tre possibili che andremo a visualizzare,
che sono: la biomassa; il carbone;
e il gas naturale.
Ora cercheremo di capire i pro e i contro,
cosa anche la scienza pensa,
quali di queste risorse naturali
sono effettivamente migliori
o potrebbero veramente riuscire
in questa transizione.
E lo faremo tramite,
fondamentalmente, tre parametri,
che ci diranno: quanto
questa risorsa è abbondante;
quanto è il suo impatto
a livello dell'ambiente;
e l'impatto a livello societario.
La prima è la biomassa,
che pur essendo molto green
ha un grande svantaggio,
come vediamo nel punto societario.
Il problema è che per riuscire
a produrre della biomassa
bisogna fondamentalmente coltivarla.
Quindi si stima, per esempio,
che per riuscire a fare bioplastiche
che riescono per esempio
a coprire il volume di plastica
del solo polietilene, polipropilene
e delle maggiori plastiche usate oggi,
si dovrebbe usare circa
il sette percento della terra agricola,
della terra coltivabile
di tutto il pianeta.
Quindi la domanda sorge quasi spontanea:
dobbiamo coltivare plastiche
o coltivare cibo per noi?
Quindi non adatto,
a livello quantomeno globale.
Secondo è il carbone
che, seppur molto abbondante
nel nostro pianeta,
è considerato la fonte fossile
più inquinante che c'è,
ancora più del petrolio in realtà.
E l'ultima è il gas naturale, appunto,
che all'esatto opposto del carbone,
pur essendo una fonte fossile
è considerata la più green tra queste.
E molti Stati stanno
piano piano cambiando,
o cercando di cambiare, i loro feedstock
da petrolio a gas naturale.
Uno dei grossi problemi di oggi,
col gas naturale, in realtà,
è che neanche il 10 percento
del gas naturale estratto tutt'oggi
è usato nell'industria chimica
per fare questi prodotti chimici,
questi intermedi,
questi prodotti della chimica di base
di cui parlavamo prima.
In realtà si stima
che circa il 3.5 percento,
una stima molto simile a quel poco
che viene usato nell'industria chimica,
viene bruciato nel cosiddetto processo
di "flaring" così come vedete qua,
perché è il modo più economico
per disfarsene.
E questo processo
in realtà brucia, si stima,
circa 15 miliardi di dollari ogni anno;
e ancora peggio, forse,
è tutta l'anidride carbonica che rilascia,
perché cercate di immaginare 70 milioni -
in questo caso di Range Rover,
o di fuoristrada,
che viaggiano per 20.000
chilometri ogni anno,
rilasciando quindi enormi quantità di CO2.
E questo vi dà così un feeling
di quello che è questo processo
per il nostro pianeta.
Ma questo processo di flaring
avviene, principalmente,
dove il gas naturale viene estratto,
come vedete qua, per esempio,
in questo video.
E il motivo principale
è che è troppo costoso,
tramite per esempio gasdotti,
trasportare in molti dei casi questo gas
a questi impianti di produzione chimica,
dove può essere trasformato
e l'albero dell'industria chimica
può essere formato per così dire.
La mia idea, la mia visione
è che invece di portare
il gas all'impianto
è esattamente il contrario:
portare l'impianto al gas,
con il cosiddetto "plant on wheels",
praticamente come questo camion
che arriva alla risorsa,
al sito di estrazione del gas,
evita quindi di dover trasportarlo
e riesce invece a trasformarlo
"on site" - sul sito -
e quindi finire il processo di flaring,
eliminarlo completamente.
E questo è possibile tramite tecnologie
che sono in fase di sviluppo oggi,
una delle quali è quella
su cui sto lavorando,
che ho sviluppato
negli ultimi cinque anni a Zurigo.
In realtà una cosa importante,
prima di chiudere,
è che questo processo di flaring
non è un processo, o un problema,
che viene deciso magari da qualche sceicco
in qualche deserto sperduto,
ma in realtà è qualcosa
decisa fondamentalmente da noi,
o comunque da chi ci rappresenta.
Voglio farvi un esempio
molto forte, degli Stati Uniti,
che sono anche un paese
produttore di gas naturale.
Già durante il governo Obama,
il governo aveva messo fuori una legge
che stabiliva, o quantomeno regolava
questo processo di flaring,
che ahimè già nel 2017, col governo Trump,
è stata ovviamente eliminata.
Questo è già costato
nell'ultimo anno, si stima,
circa un miliardo di dollari di perdite
al governo americano,
più enormi quantità di CO2
ovviamente rilasciate nell'atmosfera.
Quindi, tornando all'esempio dell'uovo,
dove nel caso della Svizzera
il popolo svizzero ha deciso,
conscio di adottare un cambiamento
per il bene della società,
in quel caso della società svizzera,
noi oggi abbiamo il dovere
di essere consci di quello che succede
e di quali innovazioni abbiamo bisogno,
soprattutto per riuscire
ad avere un cambiamento
per il bene delle generazioni future,
e soprattutto per il bene
del nostro pianeta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)